I smell a retirement soon from him you  think he's gonna retire yeah and the UFC  is just not it's not what it was I think  it kind of already peaked you think the  UFC has peaked yeah they have some stars  like two the heydays there was like 30  Stars 20 stars that could all sell  pay-per-views and now there's different  organizations that are competing also  boxing has made a major comeback there's  other Combat Sports so no one's just  sitting around watching the UFC anymore  there's tons of exciting boxing fights  all the time they peaked with with  McGregor McGregor versus khabib like  that was the peak they'll never get  anything like that